oh you can kind of feel it right the
weather's changing
fall is right around the corner i'm
talking about the fall of the democrats
it's been a terrible awful week for them
capped off by a miserable three-hour
debate on abc
first there are signs that the democrats
will give trump a win they didn't want
to do this but they're going to give
trump a win
and i think they're going to allow a
vote on that usmca the new u.s mexico
canada free trade deal
even the washington post i almost fell
over and i read this
said it's a no-brainer bring the thing
up for a vote
second reason it's been a bad week for
the democrats the dow is now
up around 27 000. the s p is at 3
000. well that's near record territory
for the dow
up for the eighth straight day
now what does this indicate renewed
optimism among consumers
and businesses and this is important
toward the close
of this year the president and his team
they're still open to a trade deal with
china
a tight labor market here at home that
means wages
continue now see a little bit of an
uptick that's all good news i love a
tight labor market
third the democrats have
absolutely no answer for trump on the
economy
instead what we heard at last night's
debate
were the same tired platitudes
we can use trade to help build a
stronger
economy what we should be doing is
creating an economy that works for all
of us
not one percent the goal of my campaign
is to make this an economy that allows
us to live
our human values and aspirations
we're already doing that andrew in a few
moments we're going to be analyzing the
democrat debate in the only way that it
makes sense
by the way with brutal satire but first
let me say that no one on that stage
last night
looked strong enough to beat trump in
2020. i don't want to get too
up you know too confident too over my
skis to use another tired analogy
but they just did not look like they're
going to be able to stand on a stage
and debate this president on his
accomplishments
because the democrat candidate leading
the pack still
after all their efforts to take him down
could barely string
together two coherent sentences
i'm the guy that brought the brady bill
into in the focus and became law
i've been in and out of afghanistan not
with a gun it's three different
countries pakistan owns the three
counties and the counties run it i will
go on and on i'm the vice president
united states
well he was no longer the vice president
but it felt good to say that i'm sure
all the democrats on stage demonstrated
in one way or another that they're just
simply
they're not competent to govern even
liberals know that this isn't working
the lefty publication
slate eviscerated biden's answer to the
question on reparations
and all slate did was merely publish
biden's incoherent answer in full
and when abc moderators raised the issue
of trade
everyone on stage except andrew yang
was caught stumbling or responded again
with meaningless bromides they look like
they were kind of
seventh graders shocked about a surprise
question that
their teacher dropped in on a history
exam it's like we could ask about that
elizabeth warren she says proudly
that she's gonna ban all fracking good
luck winning texas with that position
liz
beto's gun buyback it's a gun ban it's
just spelled differently
not happening and bernie sanders
he just always seems angry he kind of
looks like he belongs with that
waldorf and statler from the muppets
well that's that's a good look
all kidding aside this is our future
this is our lives this is america our
the money that everybody's earned worked
so hard to
earn over the past few years and do i
think americans are going to turn that
all over all those gains to
what elizabeth warren and her green rod
new deal
or let julian let him all in castro
throw open our
country's borders no way
compare trump's record of peace and
prosperity to what will
undoubtedly happen if one of the top dem
contenders wins
i gotta say i don't even think it's
close
people who don't know a lot about
politics are sure
they're absolutely sure that trump's
personality his tweets
and his tone it's all going to sink him
he's too abrasive he's too cocky
he swings at too many pitches blah blah
blah
well all i say i'll say about that is a
lot of people
they don't like bill belichick either
it's kind of gruff he doesn't smile much
but guess what belichick wins
and wins and wins a lot of people do
like him especially when he wins
well the truth is obama really was a
great politician
we just got to be honest about that he
was terrific captivated a crowd
but none of the dems running now really
are
and i don't even think it's their fault
it's just not in their dna it's not in
their skill set
something what should these folks do
well joe biden should move on
and maybe write his memoir tell old
yarns about his life in the senate or
growing up
as a young boy mayor pete
oh he can actually just go back to south
bend and try to fix the
horrible crime problem there and then
elizabeth warren she can go back to the
sequestered life on a college campus
maybe do some dna research bernie
sanders he should just leave politics
and run one of those
free socialist circulars that you can
get at the supermarket
rails against corrupt local politicians
are always stacked up
maybe julian castro can go assist
migrant families at the border there's a
lot of work to be done there
and cory booker he can i don't know
start his own
vegan youtube channel big business there
amy klobuchar she should go be a partner
at
some big boring law firm and just start
ordering associates around
kamala harris she would be a good
president
at like a small liberal arts college
or maybe she'd be a good local
television anchor i could see that
o'rourke he should run a school of rock
franchise he's a lot of experience in
that arena
but none of them and i mean none of them
should ever get close to 1600
pennsylvania avenue
and that's the angle